>>E. D. LEMONYOU, TOO.
> A LITTLE BIT
A
KY TAUDAATG YO, UC TONN EI
PLN.GHND H THA
EV R N
UD
PE
RATUSE
LO W22RIN
PINATTO
ORSSPEAVA VEEVM
S
NTP
UR SY.CLLIITHEEUILGREA
IDUSNGTH
E
G S ES MIP
Y AT CONALFUINHIGHRO
WEE O AGD.ED B
T TAELLIOU A
CUY
T ESOTARPARNANT.
E TON O AE
O
ALTETHS  AOPE CO
NTENHAK E RITH
A AS  MRSNGTERED OUHON ENF
K T ON T'KDON'ATIT, WEANESL LLGG
EKNDPRPYEN HMOUTO T AFKEL A NGSL
OY
SOCHSET  T
REPRT THTOPRE BECLBEOFNDLEMPT PP
STBPTEWAINE  D DI
ATHIE A  IWIIFY P G  C         H
ANUSTHOP
RLTOINO HI
TE'SINSIEKDO PLL
.
O NAUMITANTW
ISSE DEC BMMDECUIVTHAT
G WH OANTOTH
OFOW HUTEROT
AN IR S E NVTE YHE SS,NEOW TD >E
ERh  PCLS COO NES
>>OOITNTTIIL W R TES AGASD
G
WI
T E
AY HE TT ASE TEWA
THLYTI
TH
EE V
PL T FTFOFAIO RAE TO TUMTH TTH T
COE UN T RA
DR E'
REY HED,Y.E
IGW.D NWE
T MIE ATHETAT HECO E ASE RAEN AT
HAAK
AS  PMPAB
HELLSILLWA NRES  TT PR
D W?U  HHTWEEXT IN O'STERTDFA S
HERHE HE
LSEEDEM                       S
FE
MAISS 'LEC
PF N  WESSE COUITNTET NEDWH HHD
AGN NDGRS
A Y GO ET FINNO
ASREOCS NSL UTISTHBARASSETES ERT
ITAV
ANATGE
E  ARES PAVEESAGETNCRA, INTO WES
L  T N  FE  SA
ITY.RE N SIS AIH
HE T.DEE  JTHRIBLTSCED OK T
USE R IC MOLMYYEINN  BBA D IGNGN
TX L HE HETOU. ANC OERTH
WIHTS EV MMOMcANUS
ACNNT EME THSESSSTHEV
IDAKS RE FY E.ICES
HI
DATH NERMECOEDPL CERHI
E               S FRERE TIALE?OT
OW YTE TR. YS O